[Music]
uh good evening everybody
thank you for coming along on this uh
chilly and invigorating and apple
evening for our candidates briefing
session i'm michael morris i'm the
deputy electoral officer and manager of
governance and legal here at the city
council
and we'll
be doing the basic introduction stuff
and then handing over presenting tonight
we have uh claire headley the chief
executive of cuba city amy from the
southland regional council i had a
statement to read from uh chris on
behalf of the invertebrate licensing
trust and then we have anthony morton
who is the electoral officer for indigo
city
southland regional council of southland
district council or district council in
case you were wondering
um so quick
safety briefing
and the event of an emergency
sirens will sound and please follow the
staff after the building we will be
assembling
and helping the car park uh
to follow the instructions of staff and
toilets as i'm sure you're all aware
over by the stairs should you need them
so
that is it for me at the moment so
without further ado i'll invite you
thanks michael
and like you i'll take my mask off while
i'm speaking can i say how great it is
to see
number of people here this evening and a
range of ages and i look forward to
hearing from michael that we've had a
good number of nomination forms fine
so what's local government all about
first off i should say that i am
speaking on behalf of a territorial
authority a district council amy will
cover up environment environment
southland
from
uh the in the capital city's point of
view local government is a very complex
business the role of a councillor is not
a full-time job but it's not a hobby
there are
more than 125 different pieces of
legislation
we're responsible for formula for
formulating the district's strategic
direction
and we do that in conjunction with the
community through the long-term plan we
do advocacy to central government and to
others on what our district needs we
determine the services and activities to
be undertaken by the council as a result
of feedback from the community
we are responsible for managing
regulations we're not the most popular
in this particular activity upholding
the law
and
that includes formulating and
enforcement of buy laws we actually have
a law making power
we
um
we've got environmental management
through the district plan and we've
certainly got the role of ensuring that
local communities voices heard as part
of decision making processes of central
government also this is quite a lot that
gets involved
last week
i was speaking to a mayor of a
authority that would be of not a similar
size to ours and his comment was that he
thought he had the role of me down for
about 25 hours a week
very focused on where he can add value
and what he's he's driving
i could speak to a mayor of another
authority of a similar size or maybe
smaller and they would say they do 65
hours a week
it's the same for a counsellor
but if it's not a hobby what i would say
is that it's a role that shouldn't be
taken lightly it's an important
responsibility particularly when you
think about buy laws but you think about
the proven use of rate players money
you are representing and leading the
district and you're involved in advocacy
and governance i'm responsible for
implementing council's decisions
so there is a real need for the council
laws to sit and identify what is needed
in the community what action the council
should take what expenditure should be
applied to it in a strategic sense and
then i'm responsible for implementing
implementing that through the
approximately 400 people that work in an
incredible city
there is a skill set set out in the
candidate handbook that you will be able
to pick up as you leave
what are you what do i think that you
might demonstrate
if you're interested in standing for
council
you're likely to have a genuine interest
in a wide range of issues faced by local
communities
you're likely to relate to a wide range
of people and quite frankly have good
people skills you're probably going to
get energy from engaging with people and
finding out what makes them tick and
what they think needs to happen in the
local community
able to use good listening skills but
also be able to have good public
speaking skills
two of the things and i'll go absolutely
off script
i think one of the hardest things for a
counsellor is not knowing who your 12
colleagues are going to be
when you
put your hand up
if you're elected because if you go for
a job interview you get interviewed by
one or two people that you get a sense
of who they are you can get a sense of
the reputation of the people around you
you sit at a table and you have
no voice other than that ability to
debate
but you can't achieve anything unless
you can get a majority vote so you need
to be able to articulate and debate to
be able to influence others
and i think that's a challenge for
people that they you need to be able to
appreciate that what's really important
to you being that table might not be
important to the others around the table
so you need to hear what's important to
them and work with them on their issues
in the expectation that they'll work
with you on yours
the other thing that i would say that's
quite difficult for
candidates or for
council laws
is that
they need to be able to defend their
decisions
when they're out at supermarket at the
swimming pool at the library at the
rugby field
and sometimes those decisions will have
been made in public excluded and you're
not able to share the greater amount of
information that you had
but people will say what did you do that
for
and you'll find yourself to having
to defend how you voted on something or
indeed you might not have voted for it
but the majority did and you might have
to
articulate why the council came to the
decision that it did do
the decision i've made so you're likely
to be able to express your ideas clearly
and be results focused because we're
there to make a difference what are the
results that you're looking for
and
you're going to get some complex issues
and it's my team's job to be able to put
those in a report
you are going to read a lot
so anybody sitting at the council table
you are going to read a lot
so you're likely to be able to
understand
and analyze what's being told to you in
a report able to then ask questions of
that report
and be able to as part of the group
resolve some complex issues
all of us will find it more comfortable
if you appreciate the difference between
governance and management
one of my colleagues talks about council
is having noses in fingers out
you're interested in the business but
you're not in the business
the staff are in the business and i
report to you along the activities of
the staff
you're likely to think district-wide
you're likely to think city-wide and for
somewhere like in the cargo city that's
probably easier than somewhere like
southland district which has a number of
different communities
and the last thing that i would say is
that you need to be
willing to commit to the elected members
code of conduct
to that
agreed
behaviors for councillors that we have
at invercargill what again
what are the arrangements around council
meetings at the moment and i say this
because it changes
with each council they can choose their
own layout but at the moment council
meetings are every four weeks we have
infrastructure committee meets on the
first tuesday of the month
performance policy and partnerships
meets on the second tuesday of the month
and council meets on the fourth tuesday
of the month there's other subcommittees
working groups that and you can be
invited into briefings on topics
you can see the 2022 meeting agenda but
you won't necessarily get to see the
extraordinary meetings that have been
held we try not to recall too many of
those and we certainly try and put them
on a tuesday afternoon on the back of
another commitment that you may have had
for a meeting
um
flexible working hours well they don't
come more flexible than the counselors
you might get a phone call at six in the
morning or at 10 at night
and you can work in
the other things around your life around
it what's the remuneration that's shown
there again
incoming council chooses to determine
committees and
determine
the allocation of the pool of
remuneration across the councillors the
mayoral remuneration is set by the
remuneration authority the rest is the
subject of a pool
established by the remuneration
authority and councillors must allocate
all of that poll
but they
look at what the workload is across the
members of
it's patent fortnightly you are deemed
to be an independent contractor
so although you are paid through the
payroll of council you are deemed to be
an independent contractor you're
responsible for your own acc levies your
own
student loan repayments if you have them
and
reporting eird
in terms of tax arrangements
i think that's about me but i would say
to you and anybody that you know that is
interested in standing i'm happy to meet
with anyone at any time and answer any
questions if they've got them as i'm
sure my killers too
okay
amy i think you're going to stand and
and i think we'll probably have
questions at the end yeah yeah cool
thank you
it's nice to take it off
everybody i'm amy kubrick i'm the
general manager corporate for
environment southland
to tell china which is southern regional
council and i wanted to take the time
this evening to talk to you a little bit
about what the regional council does
because despite looking after the entire
southland region it probably is one of
the lesser known councils in terms of
its activities
and people often don't understand why
they have to pay two sets of rates
so the regional council is responsible
for managing the environmental
the resource and the transport planning
issues for our region we've also got
harbour master responsibilities
and we have a role in responding to
climate change
and community resilience for the
opportunities and the threats that are
presented by that
there's an enormous breadth to the work
that we do
i've cleared talked about the number of
pieces of legislation that they're
governed
uh
local government and whilst
i don't think we've got as many as the
territorial authorities we certainly
have a significant number
and the most significant piece that we
work with is the resource management act
and basically that act charges us with
the integrated management of the natural
and physical resources in the region so
we charge to do that so there's a
sustainable future for
people who live in southland now and
people are going to be living in south
london later on and that future is not
just for the people but it's for the
future of the environment itself so ours
is a very long-term view of what we do
the haworah the resilience of our region
its waterways its coast its land
the people and the flora and fauna that
exist here are at the heart of all that
we do
so we have a significant regulatory role
we create the regional policy statement
for the whole of the southern region
including
and this is the highest ranking local
government planning document in the
region which directs our organisation
and the other councils in the region on
resource management issues and how we're
supposed to address them
so as a regulator part of our role is to
develop the rules according to national
direction from central government and in
consultation with the community
and
in addition to the uh
legislation we also have a whole bunch
of national standards for things like
ear and water and indigenous
biodiversity
there are national policy statements
national operating frameworks and we
have to translate that direction from
central government and incorporate that
into our local plans such as the
proposed south and water and land plan
and our regional year plan
but it's not a one-way street so when
there are changes the legislation or
when there's new legislation being
proposed we also respond to there and we
advocate to government on southland's
behalf in relation to those things that
impact us as a region
typically we perform our regulatory role
through policy and planning
through issuing consents for individuals
and organisations to undertake
activities which might impact
on the environment and which are already
covered by our plans and we also perform
monitoring
and other work to ensure that our plans
and consents are being uh complied with
but we are so much more than rules and
regulations and rates we're also
concerned with soil conservation water
quantity and quality equality
biosecurity and biodiversity protection
marine and freshwater ecosystems
the avoidance and mitigation of natural
hazards which we have to identify and
monitor and we also undertake activities
in the coastal marine space
we undertake environmental monitoring we
collect data about all the things that
i've just talked about
and we turn it into meaningful
information which we use to give effect
to our work
the people that work for us are highly
skilled
very educated and they come from all
around the world
and in addition to our policy and
planning specialists our consenting
compliance teams we have people like
scientists biodiversity officers river
engineers agricultural specialists
geographic information systems
specialist which has got a mouthful just
just to name a few
and we're able to attract and retain
quality people because the region that
we support is dynamic beautiful
challenging varied the work is
interesting
and and the nature of the work we do has
inherent meaning as well
but we don't work alone we value
enormously our relationship with uh ewe
and the partnership that we have here
with them that gives effect to our role
so we work closely as the other councils
do with taobao
and they represent naitahu kimurihuku
for resource management and local
government
and so with ewe we've been able to weave
together a set of objectives
representing community and eb values for
fresh water
we were the first and we're still
currently the only region in new zealand
that's been able to do that
we also have monophenol representation
on two of our council committees and
we're involved across our programs as
well so notably they are currently
co-managing our people water and land
program which is designed to give effect
to the national policy statement for
fresh water management and approval
equality here in southern
we also work with our other councils
government agencies industry and other
local and national bodies in our work
and importantly we work with our local
communities when we're trying to affect
change on the ground
like our other like our other councils
and we programmed priorities and budgets
are lay down in our long-term plan and i
won't labor that because clear's already
talked about that
and our document is on our website if
you would like to know more
so what does it mean to be a counselor
for us well firstly we have 12
councillors and they cover six
constituency
uh
constituency areas within the region and
it's not a nice two person per
constituency it's it's quite varied
there are six for the infocable uh
area and then
uh varied amounts for the other areas
chairman deputy chairman and committee
chairs are selected by councillors at
the inaugural meeting of council
following the election
we've got regular meetings of full
council and committees and subcommittees
of council and and that currently held
during the week but as she said you know
the new council some committees and
timetables so so that may change
so overall and and
like the other council councils our
councillors represent their communities
for three-year terms
they set policies they make regulatory
decisions
they review council performance
they approve our council's overall
budget
and they set the rates
they set our strategic direction and our
priorities employ monitor the
performance of the chief executive and
they attend regular meetings
i think it's fair to say when your
council and no two days are even the
same so
if you like variety have we got the job
for you
there's a lot to get your head around as
clear said there is a lot of reading
uh
some of the information that you deal
with is quite complex and we also run
regular briefings for our counsellors
and a series of workshops to help them
understand issues before they have to
sit down and make decisions of them in
full counsel
those who like to get their gum boots
uh or we leave gunboats from time to
time occasionally we get a chance to
dress up and uh come into town and
and ten various meetings with partner
agencies other councils industry bodies
as required as well as the regular
council meetings we throw in visits from
the occasional government minister or
representatives and there's a sort of a
pick and mix assortment really of
community-based and information-based
meetings entries as well
uh those who
aren't gonna be wearing do get a pair of
gumboots to go out and take undertake
site visits to see what we're doing on
the ground and to understand how we are
making a difference out of the community
firsthand
you get to talk to various parts of the
community that our work effect and see
how we're making a difference
and as councillors you also get the
opportunity to converse with your
constituents and get involved
in your constituents
and your constituency on issues that are
important
to them
at our regular subcommittee and
committee meetings and council meetings
you get to debate issues with your
council colleagues make decisions and
shape policy
and if it's one thing just to pick up on
the comments you made about one of the
challenges that um
then i see that that or one of the
things that i think
can be a challenge for counsellors is
knowing and understanding what happened
hearing when so often when you come to
the council
table you are there to represent a
particular point of view and and by all
means it's really important that we get
those views out there expressed and on
the table but your role as a counselor
when you're making a decision as a
counselor and you're you're taking the
account of what everybody said and
making a decision for the benefit of the
region as a whole and that can be tough
sometimes as well
um
so
you know legacy is important and i think
one of the things that being a counselor
gives you is that opportunity to
help
shape and create the future whether
that's for the city whether it's for the
district or whether it's for the for
olive region so if that's if that's a
way that you would like to make your
mark i would strongly encourage you to
fill out that form
and uh become a counsellor thank you
[Applause]
thanks
amy chris over here
chris ramsay from the ilt since his
apologies to be here has not been able
um so i'm sure i know if you know the
licensing trust is a community-owned
organization that serves the people of
memphis
they've owned and operates 24 successful
hospitality businesses
uh there will soon be 29 ones with the
england's hotel review in the coming
months the businesses range from
accommodation and pubs to bottle stores
and distribution
the iot's model is a unique form of
social enterprise that has all
its diverse parts contributing a share
of its profits back to the community
joining our ilt board presents a rare
opportunity to play an active role in
helping direct funding to the community
to ensure it has a long-lasting positive
impact on invercargill and its people
since its inception in 1944 iot has
given over 200 million dollars back to
the community
of over capital through grants and
donations it is administered under the
provisions of the sale and supply of
alcohol act 2012 in case you are
wondering
and its mandates include establish motel
accommodation operate licensed premises
and the interest of public well-being
establish model accommodation sorry not
motels and distribute the profits
for the community purposes they have two
two board meetings per month and these
are typically held on the last two
thursdays of each month starting at four
and last for approximately two hours and
i'm sure
clear myself and amy and the team at the
regional council as well as robin who is
here from sdc
if anyone's interested in finding out
more just make contact we're happy to
help and with that we will now hand over
to what is billed as the main event
that's anthony in our electoral visit
all right
[Music]
the south district council and
foreign's covered
um so i'm here to try and cover up for
you as candidates more of what you can
expect to go through
if you're on a candidacy
council
in principle
what you need to do without violation
fruit
cover of some technical bits like
what you need to do with your chemical
profile and photo if you're going to
submit one
um things like
campaigning and get into that mode and
what the rules are in that are
and then finally look at some of the
results stuff so
that's the problem is what we're going
to try and cover up in the next 20
minutes maybe 30
um so this is a icc hosted event so most
of the slides you're going to see are
going to be directed at icc
but actually we've seen from the current
remaining and statement from chris
michael
um we're trying to
be more of a global let's bring more of
a global aspect or a provincial aspect
into the election process this time
which is why the other speakers have had
an opportunity to
address us
and you i'll try and cover those off if
anybody's specifically interested in
those other
nomination processes as we go through
those various slides
um
so i just wanted to start with some
background information so i'm
employed by elections.com
and that's a little bit about the
company that i think calls me so i'm an
electoral administrator if you want to
know during daytime
and
we are based in christchurch we do about
200 elections on a typical year
some of them are very small it could be
just the local chamber of common
selections
uh some of them are quite big so at the
moment we're doing something we're doing
the election process for the corporate
bank which is over 120 000 members
and then we get across the various
other cooperatives like fonterra like
ravenstown those sort of industry groups
we also do a lot of peewee
ratification polls those sort of things
so that's what we're doing through the
process but every three years we're
involved in council actions
and
you can see from the range there those
are the councils that we have been
engaged by and to process either just
their voting papers
or in this case for both southland or
sorry for south london
and gore to carry out their original
officer functions and through that we've
looked at the advice's interest as well
so that's a little bit of background
information about that company and where
i set it
as electoral officer i'm that person
responsible for the conduct of the
election so if there's fire
or the final decisions to be made the
risk complaint i'm not responsible to
the council even though they engage us
but we work with those councils on an
administrative basis through the likes
of michael
team
and we are trying to provide a little
playing field
with some reasonably light legislation
down the bottom of the slide there about
uh we monitor
we don't want our campaigning activities
but
so if the candidates are having a
squabble we're not interested in that
you have to
grow a thicker skin and put up with
somebody calling you in public
we deal with the breaches of the
legislation and usually that comes down
to signage placements like that and
stuff like that
and
bridges of decorations and things
further down the track and cover that up
for the
presentation
so for this particular election
michael is the deputy committee for
officers that is the man on the ground
in the capital here i'm based in
christchurch and i've supported them
through that process
michael will hand out or organize the
documentation and we'll organize the
team
so that's the timetable up there
it's the abbreviated timetable
i'm not going to go through all those
dates but the ones i do want to point
out is the first one
so this 8th of july date there which is
the election period starts is the period
three months out from the actual project
closing date
and that just signifies when candidates
need to start tracking their expenditure
and we'll cover that up a little bit
further in the presentation but that's a
reasonably important date for you to
just note
obviously your nominations don't open
until the 15th of july but uh and close
on the 12th of august you've got about
four weeks
and uh the last one that you're probably
more interested in is when the results
come in which is this year um
there's some initial
so let's have a look at this nomination
process itself
so those are the positions up for grants
for in the cargo city
electives if you like
so
mere 12 councillors in this case were in
capital city fight members from
licensing trust for most of the
collectors in
capital city
just to note that that area doesn't
cover the full
area
so
the nomination process what we want to
for you to get your name on the voting
document
you need to firstly submit a nomination
form
and if you've been through that process
in 2019
take a bit of a relief and the whole
process is very similar
the paperwork side of it shouldn't
change much
but you do need to submit a nomination
form
and you do need to pay a 200 deposit for
every position you want to stand for
the evidence of new zealand citizenship
is required
just to prove that you are a citizen
because
that's one of the conditions of
eligibility
and
the profile
cabinet profile and the photo are
optional but most candidates choose to
put them in and we'll go through
the technicalities of those for
the
presentation
so their forms are available in this
case indicating the city from the
indicator city office
offices
and from the website
so the handbook is up there now the
nomination forms will be on the website
i think we'll get over there okay
um now and you see the selection hub
office
note there that's conditional on being
available
if there will be a hub officer
in the southland region to come together
to provide a seamless ability for all
people to vote
and the idea is that there will be a
central hub uh here and
uh in gall uh where people can come and
vote so it doesn't matter if you're from
southland in southern district you're
from town i'll come into town for the
day and you want to make a special boat
you will be able to do that in a
vacation and if you're into town you
should be able to do a vote from a
parachute sitting there quite nicely so
the hub is we're still working on it
it will be something that we will
announce on our website and facebook and
media once it's available
we're very pleased with this initiative
and very
happy that we're able to work together
with all of our councils on those
standards under the label invoked
you will see the little whale tail on
the front page of the candidate's
handbook that's the logo to know that
you are looking at elections exactly
so the hub office will be available for
procedure nominations as well
the teach leader will advertise that
once that
certainly the forms are available from
in this case on the
council's offices
and the same employees for southern
district and environment south so
building those
themselves but just keep in mind we need
to return them if you are looking to be
a candidate because they're not
necessarily to go back to that
districts will go through to southern
districts um
environment southampton will come back
through to
sorry south districts
fourth street office
so those details are in the on the
nomination form as
but also to be aware that you have a
little contact details are generally
made public after the event by way of a
spreadsheet of collective deals so
people like the newspaper or
members of the public
sales people wanting to send you some
advertising space will have the ability
to come back and contact you
no but it's up to you as to whether you
want that with help so
address isn't expected it's usually just
phone numbers
[Music]
so just be aware that your details will
be made or will be released after the
nominations
unless you ask for them to be suppressed
but there is a requirement to have at
least a platform
yep okay so
these eligibility criteria
the first stuff is pretty much
straightforward i think in terms of
general points
for councils you don't have to live in
the area if you are a candidate but your
two nominators
nominators have to be
rolled within that area and their
ability to vote
so um
you can stand for
council
mia and community board if you want to
for icc
future but that's three lots of 200 if
that's going to be the case you can
stand on the ilt and council if you want
to
and
you must state on the nomination form
whether you live or don't live within
the area that you would stand before and
the other big thing there is you can't
withdraw after nominations close
so
if you are thinking
district council
you
you need oag approval or obviously
ordered a general images
will you get that before nominations
close
well sometimes it can
but typically that process is a post
uh nomination of those
i just want to make it clear to people
because
um
we do have councillors across the
country that have business with the
councils
and so you've got there cannot but
actually they can stand as long as they
get the oig approval first yeah thank
you
all right um
if you haven't seen it before that's a
typical nomination
other than to just point out that
there's a two page
front page covers
at the top part of the front page covers
the candidate details so that's where
you listen to the details of your
the one part below that is for your
nominators to complete
the back page is
has eligibility criteria in the top part
and below that we'll have a little bit
more detail but below there's some
information about
your bank account to pay your deposit to
if that's how you want to do it
online
and below that there's a little um
that's where it's going to get back to
so that part of it doesn't get disclosed
as public information that's just for
our punishment
so just to point out a few things on
that front page of nomination form so
up the top and you wanted to squint
there's a couple of little radio circles
there about whether they live within the
area or outside the area so that's where
you just check
that you might have been deleted for
intensive purposes and won't be standing
for a position down here that's allowed
but if you do you need to know there
that you live without outside the area
and below the um let me just show you
several other boxes here
one of which is
uh i wish my name to be shown on the
loading document as
so that's an important field to look for
if you're known as
tom brady let's say but your full name
is thomas edward brian brady or
something
you may have submitted your full name at
the top there so we can check you off on
the natural roll but unless you complete
that and say you want to be listed as
tom brady you will be listed as thomas
edmond brian brady
which
when everybody else is just doing an
abbreviated version usually just first
night
that stands out and people go well why
because my whole name
so just to keep that in mind um
the rest of that i think it will be
reasonably straightforward as i say it
should be always the same formula last
year or 2019
before
so
should be reasonably familiar
all right
let's have a look at this candidate
profile
besides
so they're not compulsory you don't have
to submit one but most candidates do
it's pretty miserable in terms of the
number of words you get to
talk about yourself 150 words gets
chewed up pretty quick
um
what we'd say about that is and i'll
show you the next slide
on the next slides we'll show you how
things fit together but what i encourage
you to do is don't waste your time like
putting your opening sentence my name is
because your name will be listed above
your photo
and it'll be originally obvious who you
are so
there's a few words saved at least but
you can't
comment on your own oh sorry you need to
comment on people commentary to your
particular policies or
whatever you want to project don't go
working on other
candidates policies
and again they need to go up on the
account or they will go up on the
council website
accommodations close so that people can
see
who they're going to be voting for
we do want a an electronic version of
the nomination i'm sorry that
canada profile please
so
either email a copy of it or bring it on
a memory sticker or a flash drive or
whatever it's going to be and hand it
over with the nomination
[Music]
pick it up and retype it and in that
process make mistakes that
you will only see on
any other document
so if you can give us what you have
submitted
we can then just copy and paste that and
what is happening
and the point to be to note from that is
that ideally it comes as either a word
document
or if it's a pdf then it's going to be
you've got to be able to copy the
content out of the pdf so don't print it
off then scan it and email that through
because that's
just
all right so
that's the profile side of it
um the photos
they need to be recent because it took
and
don't get too worried about
how big the photo is or the
the context of it
we will crop it accordingly as best we
can but
if you're going to do a hand
drawn photo we'd encourage you to take
it up against a white background so lock
a window or something like that and to
just be conscious of the logic that's
so things like um no sunglasses no hats
some sort of clear
photo that people will have a reasonable
chance of recognising you
so we need to be able to just identify
you clearly
and this is how they fit together so in
the handbook
in this case it is this is just a mocked
up one but this is my colleague
um so you can see that
in there it's listed under okay with
city council
these are the barrel candidates again
lists his name
below that is the affiliation that he
wants to
use
and he's put a wee bit of thought into
that
um
below that is a statement saying whether
he lives in or outside the area
you know this case is told to lie and
said he lives in the orange so it's in
here he actually doesn't
and he's also standing in this case for
a council a council
so he's standing on there plus the
council and that is 150 word profile
would follow back
so you can see that it's quite clearly
labeled who he is you don't need that my
name is your opening line
all right and it's photographers
yes
that is what it is
so those are the things you need to get
the nomination form in a
completed nomination and that will be
checked
the deposit
the profile if you're having one and the
photo and evidence of your
citizenship
all right after a bit of campaigning
side events
so you can kick off your camp burning
any time you like it could have been
campaigning last year if you want to but
there's a few things that you need to
just keep in mind
the principle thing
principle message is
you need to stick to your own resources
so if you don't hire the item you're
trying to use in your campaign
or you haven't got permission to use it
you probably shouldn't
that generally goes more for the council
resources so
council logos
iot logos
those sort of things keep away from them
likewise
youtube council buildings and council
staff to support your education
don't use that council resources
as
candidates you generally shouldn't be
trying to pick up voting papers for
collectors
simply because of the perception that
gives that you could then interfere with
that process so leave it alone they have
got to reply pay down or if they can't
get there then they should
get somebody else to get into the
council ballot box
there's a general rule we try and tell
candidates to keep away from that
in this case in the cable's case they've
got a specific policy about not
campaigning on council purposes
and i think that extends to signage
when we cover that off that
you can't have a sign that's visible
within the
people or from the council building or
something that effective
yeah so all that information is
documented in the handbook
in a bit more detail
but as i noted there earlier
if you are a candidate you need to
submit a declaration at the end of the
voting process outlining your expenses
that you've incurred on the campaigning
side of things now you may not have any
expenses you may have to take a load
campaigning or do it very cheaply
you still need to submit a return into
the printing process
and as clear indicated before
any campaign material has to have an
organization statement on it
which at the moment because the law is
still old
requires you to state that it's
authorized by either you as a candidate
or your agent and then list either your
address or your candidate's address and
it needs to be a physical address
or
that legislation should change and the
second part of that will change to allow
you to not list and address a physical
address
you'll be allowed to list
mobile phone numbers email addresses or
website addresses where somebody can
view
that
where that particular language or
candidate can be found
we would
encourage you if you're putting it on
signs etc in particular to make sure
that that authorization statement is on
the front of the sign so it stops every
week
generally false
accusations that you haven't got an
authorization statement on there
somewhere um
any campaign material must be factual so
it's all still
subject to the
standards
so
uh as such it's
that can be complained
or the public has complaints to the
advertising standards association
and they will conduct hearings if need
be about
the validity of your campaign so
you can
if you're stating facts actually you
vaccinate
basically so you can't go running off
stupid triggers about
and that last point is the usual rules
of defamation apply so just be careful
those are the
limits that you can spend on your
campaign
now
in most cases
these are population
wondering
based
if you are standing for multiple
issues
you is the highest level
that holds and carries so if you stand
up for both the bluff community board
and the council
you can still only spend 30 000 and what
we need to point out is that that is the
candidate's money basically so usually
it's self-funded occasionally it comes
from donations and we'll cover that off
shortly
but just to confirm that there is no
magical
check or money coming out of the council
to cover your campaign expenses
we do get that people will get to the
end of the campaign period and say right
well i get my money
it's
sad to point out that that's not the
case okay so if you ever conduct them
campaigning
it's it'll be your money or money from
donations if you're
lucky
enough um
and it can't be up to that level
and you need to submit a declaration at
the end of the period to say this is
where i spent my money on because if you
didn't spend any money you just
still need to submit to no regulation
okay
so we've covered all some of that let's
refer to pages 21 and 34 of the handbook
there's a bit more detail on there
it needs to be any campaign that costs
that have been incurred from the 8th of
july at least
if you've done something prior to the
8th of july that
has a value that goes into the election
period then you have to prior to that
cost
so more particularly for some of the
bigger urban areas where they started
campaigning
months ago
they may have got a photo shoot for
something like that done for some of
their publicity material
and that cost would have happened in
so just because it happened before the
eighth of july doesn't mean we can't
forget about it some
um we need to put those declarations up
on the website so there are a document
in public inspection
so you do need to be careful about what
you put in there
because that public will be looking at
it
and somebody will use it as an
opportunity to question
how you've conducted your plan
um
there's the thing about the deposit so
each nomination has to be
supported by a 200 deposit
and it is a deposit but you you only get
deposit back if you
hold a certain level of votes
and trigger is
if you get more than 25
of the
lowest pollen successful candidate
so in the carnival cities case
whoever's the
11th hollywood candidate 12 12 candidate
uh that's the trigger point so you then
need to get 25 percent if it is 25
percent of whatever obviously you get
elected you get your nomination back
anyway
but if you're not every point
and we don't refund those deposits until
we get the declaration
there's nothing personal questions
um yeah so
donations
these are more rare um
that's the mandatory level that you have
to declare above what we
recommend is that you put any donations
in one declaration
just for the transparency so that we're
questioning further down the track can
have some confidence
that's what you do you have to have you
have to reach that point yourself as to
whether you want to do that
because you a lot of it submits the
declaration but
it has to be at least donations over
1500
um there's rules around anonymous
donations so the holidays
there are lots of non-destinations and
so
people said
normal estimation that it was
they're very tight and unless somebody
drops a bit of money up on your doorstep
which is highly unlikely
you can generally work out who that
donation came from and if you can do
that
so um it gets a little bit trickier
again have a look in the handbook most
of you won't be
affected by the donation side of things
but if you are with the handbook if it
doesn't make sense looking at the phone
or someone can help you out
at the end of the day each candidate has
to make this declaration and they are a
moment for
inspection
i think that's probably about that
under our district plan we have to apply
for a resource consent to put up
election signs during the campaign
period we're pleased to know we don't
expect you to apply for a resource
consent to do that i have done that on
behalf of all candidates um they should
be
granted very shortly so i promised
and it will allow all signs to be put up
from the end of the nomination period so
by the 12th of august your
signs can go up uh there is
now the resource consumer will be on the
website and i'm happy to make it
available to anybody who would like a
copy but what it will require is that
your signs can
pretty much go anywhere in the city
of all is that you need if you're
putting it on somebody's property other
than your own you must have their
permission
and we can ask for that to be shown if
we've got received a complaint
you can't put it on council property so
that's all our parks and observes uh
that does include our road reserve so
you need to make sure your signs are
tucked onto a fence or behind a fence a
part of that is just to protect the uh
assets underneath so we don't want you
to put your uh
boarding sign into the middle of an
electrical pipeline
um
obviously a bit of
self-preservation
um with that there are a number of rules
that our voting team have around where
it can be placed at intersections
because we all know everybody likes
putting their signs at the big t
intersections think of yarrow and
queen's drive
you cannot put it within nine meters of
an intersection so that's measured from
the curve and that includes
um
if it's a t intersection so you take
your curves um the bottom of your t
they go straight up and then it's nine
meters from there so the whole middle
pieces out as well
don't worry the team don't expect you to
immediately take something down if
there's a problem they will contact you
and ask you to move it but we will
expect you to move it
and it includes if you would like to do
some trailer advertising that's included
as well but you will require a separate
uh permission form to do that that will
be on our website that goes through our
roading team
and the final part on that is
so
one and six
and 1999 on the edge of town
you need permission from okakuta nzta to
put signs up on
the state highway network
again there's information available on
that and the handbook will be on our
website as well
covered all of that
and just in terms of
sign writing so people say
it's okay you can do that uh it is
covered in your
campaign expenses but the costs of
running your car during the campaign
aren't
considered a campaign cost just the sign
writing is
there are a number of rules around where
you can pack your car so again it can't
be visible from our cab so don't
think that it's a good idea to
be parking it in s street one car park
for example the exception to this role
as our councillors when they're on
council business they have specific
council car parks uh that they will park
in when they are at the council building
only for council business
they have very strict instructions about
that and know that we will ask them
require them to move their vehicles if
they are anywhere else or if they're not
in our building for council purposes
they council meetings during these last
few periods or when the signage is
allowed
so i think
that is probably about it for me other
than if you've got a complaint uh
candidates do complain about other
candidate signs and there's another
complaint about candidate science uh
they come into the customer environment
team uh they are responsible for that
administration
our friendly compliance team will have a
chat with you first and ask you to move
it uh if you don't move it then there
are authorities to to remove it but we
do prefer not
to have to do that because we don't want
to damage your science we do which you
know they do cost a bit of money
but no it's not anthony or my job to
monitor that
but you need to contact the council they
will take care of that so
they will now take you through a bit
more of the technical nature of science
is equipping
if you had an item with podium
and you know let's say for example in my
beautiful face on it
and
i was selling it does that count as an
impressive or for that only if it's
given away
you know
so if states in their election offenses
lower value items such as being buyers
should not be given away as part of a
campaign
but if people are buying
does that count for
yeah you can sell your little gear
you need to be careful how much you sell
it for because that would come into a
campaign yes so firstly the cost of
producing that is
but
that's something to be aware of but you
sooner can't give them away
because that's treated as indeed to be
treated
just a couple more things on the side
so that
the update for starting is for icc
because that's icc's signage rules
there will be different
rules for
south south district and different again
probably for order strings so it's
relevant to the area that you are
basically signage
what those rules are and this is for icc
this stuff here and the other point i
want to make
point out is that that authorization
statement needs to be on there
authorized by the candidate or their
agent and up until this new legislation
comes in it has to be the physical
address of that candidate
after the new registration
can be slightly different for that
second parliament but it still means
that authorization status
yeah
right one of the other points on that
previous slide was you can include a
copy of a voting document
something that symbolizes
how somebody
so here's a couple of examples of good
math science and a good one is just a
sterilization of attention for that
particular candidate
and here it's got its authorization
statement in
the one on the right is not good because
he's indicating who to vote for
with other candidate names
and
yeah the rest of it's the
it's really just the fact that it's
trying to symbolize
just his name
could be an example of somebody that's
been too honest
um that one wasn't actually a candidate
as it turned out it was indicating that
he was going to stand but
so they asked him
social media um well social media is
really just a
different way of broadcasting your
campaigning message so the same goals in
mind
in this case
keep away from council's resource which
is council's
social media channels
and they will have their own policy
about how they will
regulate that so in this case they
unlike
candidates
and they will
delete
anything they see as campaigning related
at the moment
so that's council's resource on your
resource your social media channels you
should have your authorization statement
on there somewhere saying that this page
is authorized by yourself
[Music]
it's pretty much said the same thing
let's say let's keep away from
counsellors and just use your own
resources stick to your own messaging
and
the same principle advice
election offences um stevie gray said
before so that treating
is
the situation there
where you can't
induce people to vote for you
come and have a
free beer on me as long as you vote for
me
that sort of thing you can run a
campaign meeting and you can have or
offer 10 misconceptions but it's just
including biscuits
keep away from the alcohol
can't give away t-shirts or items of
value is what legislation says but
that's generally the things that people
can trip themselves up on they'll go rip
off t-shirts or bags or pens or
something and hand them out and then we
have to tell them that that's
supply of those items
what else is unauthorized adverts is
yeah so it's really just
anything that we pick up in the way of
fences that we receive in an official
complaint they
all right so let's have a look at the
the process
itself side of things because that's
what most of you will be interested in
so
this will stop the tour of this
lecture roles if you want an electoral
wrong we can't give you the sub-economy
because the legislation doesn't allow it
you have to buy a hard copy
if you want that it's going to cost 100
there are two flavors of the electric
roll so there's one about to hit the
decks early july but july when the
nomination is open and that's the one
that we use for the station chicken
and then the final one was produced in
uh
or after
august enrollment closes the enrollment
itself comes out as attended to
mid-september that's the one they use
for issuing the money documents
again you can buy a hard copy if you
want
but
it's going to cost you 90
um
special voting
you as candidates may get approached
from people saying i've never got a
voting document
don't involve yourself in that process
because again that's this influence
factor comes into it
but
them to be able to it
up a special vote or bring up the
council when they have enough time it's
still in the process they can mail it
out to
the election hub office will probably be
up and running by then
and there will be special voting
yes
all right um
so so that special order here just
runs in conjunction to the ordinary
writing period so it's just allowing
anybody who didn't receive a voting
document to have a mechanism to get
something
is
for a couple of days in the snails
anyway
if they need us a replacement that's a
special kind of process for that
so the results this is probably what
most of you are interested in
so the results will be out initially is
a progress result which is cracked
virtually straight after voting closes
at midday on
the 8th of october
there will be probably 2 pm or
thereabouts
will potentially be ringing thus
successful candidates
was two other iterations on the result
one was preliminary result which is just
when all my ordinary votes have been
tapped up so that prohibition results
won't cover the ones that have been
dropped off to the council on the same
morning this is
the final result will be several days
later so that takes
into account the special votes that have
been processed there's a much more
old
verification process for those which is
why
so those documents for those result
documents will put up on the website
coming in novice
that doesn't happen until the day after
the results are declared
up until
last election that was the date after it
hit the government notice
newspaper legislation would then be
changed to allow that
to happen when it's
mostly to the council website so it just
means that technically the successful
candidates
they can't actually do anything
yes so let's just go through
some resources there other than the
canon
handbook is obviously the main
resource
local government new zealand
ever making in a standard
that there's
contact uh website information on the
inside camera i think it's at the handle
itself
and the council will put out this
pre-election report next month
august
and it's really just a guide for
candidates to be aware of once
yes
where there are a series of videos and
interviews with
currently vendors about the experience
of being a leader he's
hurt himself
that's great that's words
just in case any of you were hoping
there was
so there's no prizes for being the last
candidate to submit the nomination but
certainly
if you're too late
so don't leave it to the last minute
um
stick to your
own promotions
and
basically everything will play around
with yourself
you do want to just open it up for one
question
if anybody's got any questions about the
process
uh what would happen if you were a
gloriously popular got voted into lots
of different councils
all over the country yeah would you be
allowed to represent them
if you got voted
yes
technically
as long as they're not territorial and
original
so you can stand for other positions you
can't stand for the same capitalist you
can't stand for a territorial authority
within a regional power superiority
so you
can't stand force if a current city man
um but you need
people from those enrolled in those
areas to support the culmination
[Music]
so rather than declaring themselves
candidate
to be responsible for this campaign
could be a solicitor it could be an
accountant it could be your friend
most people don't have agents okay but
some people that didn't want to disclose
their home addresses under the ultimate
legislation
engaged an agent to get around them
so the expectation was that if they did
that then they had to disclose
like what's the biggest
challenge to get their head around they
might not have expected or even known
about usually
do you know i think i'd probably say
we've got two
councillors here and i'm not aware that
we've got any others i throw that
question to them because i think that's
the experience factor that
comes in
and while they're thinking about it i
would go back to that vogue haku that i
promoted before
we ran three separate occasions on
facebook live
with a total of eight
elected members some who are still in
office some who have retired from office
and they talked about their own
experience and they answered questions
that people asked and those are
available on the on the facebook page
that we've got for by
and i'd really encourage you to go and
listen to that because there's some
really good pearls of wisdom in there
but outlets or beats do you have things
you'd say
what did you not expect um
i think the sheer amount of reading
was
not something that i expected but also
the
range of things
that you have to
be across or have at least
develop a level of understanding of
because
it's not just about the things that you
care about so there's certain reasons
why i wanted to be on council and those
are the things that i was passionate
about and cared about but there's a
whole bunch of other things that i'm not
so interested in that i have to be
interested in
because it's part of the job
for me i think it was more that uh i
had a bit of a very real campaign but
i've still sort of had a bit of a shine
on me that i could get in and just
change everything or
you know like that you could just you
know you get it and you shake things up
and that you know there's young fresh
energy and that kind of thing but when i
got in and really only one or two places
changed so it was the same as we had
uh
over a series of years so
getting in and shaking things up
literally isn't possible you've got to
really um play the long game work with
people learn how to work with people or
learn how all the like things see all
the different
mechanics of it work together and how
they fit together the brief the things
that you have to be across is just
incredible
um
but yeah people learning to learn the
people the people thought up against the
offices that you're working with and the
politicians that you're working with um
to actually eventually affect change
because it's going to take a while to
get your feet
under the desk
yeah
thanks alex the other thing i'd say is
you'll never be able to go to the
supermarket in two minutes again no
okay and if you've got kids young kids
they're gonna say no debbie please don't
daddy at some stage when you go to the
supermarket you're just gonna say keep
walking
has been slightly dysfunctional
um
do you think there's a real challenge
with
i guess councils being elected and
having no government's experience
well so look what i would say is that
there's an amazing
array of professional development
opportunities to be a counsellor we run
summon house
local government new zealand organises
them and sends people down here to do
training for
all territorial authorities things like
that
um
i think that like any group changing one
or two members changes the composition
of the group
and what really counts is being willing
to listen to others and having an open
mind about working with others there is
a as part of your oath it's about having
an open mind that you come into the
council chamber not having decided your
position but actually being prepared to
listen to the views around the table
you're likely to have done a bit of
reading a bit of thinking a bit of
talking about the topic but making sure
that you're coming in prepared to listen
and
look i'd say that
how do i say this that many councils
around the country have struggled at
times with some of the composition of
the council and one that was
particularly
public was
i think it was two terms ago or um
yeah where harafinoa had a major last
term where harafino had a man and he had
particular views about what he was going
to do and
he couldn't achieve those because even
though he was the mayor he kept finding
that his council acted
as a block
because they they worked out the power
of the numbers
everything
decisions are only made at the council
table
outside the council table you have no
other powers
your superpowers only exist at the
council table the mayor has a few powers
but not many and so it's all about the
power of a majority
and that's where it comes back to
being able to work with others and
that's the thing that i think does
surprise people when length is coming
you sometimes hear about people standing
for election but on lower rates no rate
increases
only do that
if the majority votes
so everything's about the majority
yeah
they have to be enrolled for the
[Music]
[Music]
can i ask the question in a slightly
different way for the student um does
the identity of the nominators it's on
the nomination form does it get
publicized anywhere else it's only
so many people who actually go to the
website
yeah that's right it's up to the right
those nomination documents are a point
of construction but
you could give it it's not publicized
well i don't know just does
the city do that we put it on the
website
who are the nominators
[Music]
it's a bit of a horses for courses so
some councils will do this
the council's further north typically
just with the nomination the confederate
candidates
but it's just to be aware that this
council's case if they will public
documents
but going back to your original question
you should as a candidate you can
nominate somebody else
sometimes that's not in your best
interest
and also just be mindful if you've got
your nominator on the unpublished world
their data will be published as part of
that nomination form going on the
website so it's just something to
think about when you're asking your
nominators
just make sure they are happy for that
if they are on that publisher
queries
all right so so i want to close it by
saying
it may be a bureaucratic process to be
nominated and performing and to comply
with the expenses
i think that 95 of the people who stand
who are elected
discover that it's the most interesting
complex challenging rewarding
thing they can do and i would really
encourage you again if there's any
questions after this
um talk to your current elected members
each council not each council many
councils have had a period where they
haven't worked so well together
but actually it's up to the people who
stand and are elected to make that work
and
and it really is
a wonderful part of many people's lives
that they've enjoyed contributing to
their community so i really would
encourage you
thanks
just
endorse those final comments both in the
community and then in the wider sense
within entertainment at the region so
it's been going to that regional level
so with that i would say thank you all
for coming i really appreciate your
attendance tonight
please take a handbook um
deluxe have hobby edition we've also got
some for the rest of the council in case
you're interested if you've got specific
questions feel free to stand have a chat
or find them through our contact details
are on facebook or you can and find us
online
or bring our call center
that goes to the region as well and
we've got something specific for spc we
have women ralph here he's a deputy
electoral officer and she is able to
answer any questions specific to the
district council
that you may have if they do they have a
different structure for their elections
to us just in terms of how you can vote
so outside of that thank you and
good night